it's a three-dimensional hole and one of
one of my gripes that i have sometimes
with how
these sorts of things are portrayed in
movies and stuff
is they tend to think of it as like a
circle
and then you sort of fall in and you go
somewhere but where it's more of a
sphere you can approach it from many
different directions so the other side
is sort of a weird thing to think about
because it isn't you don't mean i think
the other side so much as you mean the
other place it may go to
[Music]
so pete welcome to the show yes i'm very
well
every week i'm the same really yeah i
know i should i should start differently
okay i'll start differently okay so how
are your eyes my eyes
um just like the year 2020.
whoa ladies and gentlemen peter speech
and
dropping the comedy i i would say
unfortunately that my eyes
are also like the year 2020 getting
worse
it seems every month as you as people at
home can tell i do
i do wear glasses i'm nearsighted you
can see
very well and always have been able to
right i can see a lot of things
i am i can see everything far away yeah
i can see through a lot of things like
uh
your uh cheesy openings but one thing i
can't one thing i can't see through
yes what do you think black holes
exactly well i mean
by definition very difficult to see
through right uh
black they're they're they're large
they're you know it's a
it's a massive well a massive mass
that really i think only theoretically
people believe we could see through but
again all due respect to you all due
respect to me
we're not the people who are going to be
able to answer that question so that's
why we have experts on the show
and today we do have an expert from the
university of southern california
a professor from the physics and
astronomy department
you know him you love him he's a friend
of the show professor clifford johnson
welcome back
welcome back to what if discussed hi how
are you
good well we're good we're we're kind of
debating uh well i
don't know if we're debating but we're
trying to to figure out you'd know if i
was debating could you see through a
black hole and obviously
this is theoretical so you know this is
this is the time to be a theoretical
physicist let's start with
ken what would you see if you looked
into a black hole
uh that's a great question so well
to a first approximation in my you know
physicist way of saying things
uh you wouldn't see anything coming from
the inside
because in some ways by definition at
least in classical physics
the black hole is not letting anything
escape from it
now one of the things people think about
a lot
in recent times has been black holes say
when you combine them with quantum
physics because when quantum physics is
included
there is some sort of mechanism which
goes back to
stephen hawking who you may have heard
of right who said
uh and showed that when you combine
quantum physics with black holes there's
a sense in which they radiate
stuff out and there's a way of thinking
about it
that means that in some sense the stuff
is coming out
uh energy is coming out from the black
hole it's losing energy
now one perspective says it's just some
quantum stuff happening near the horizon
and it comes out and it isn't really
coming from the inside
but another perspective says that in
some sense it is telling you stuff about
the inside of a black hole
so people are very excited about
trying to understand the full quantum
story of a black hole
because it tells you essentially about
the fate of the black hole the fate
of what fell in ultimately that stuff
all has to come out
this process by which the black hole
evaporates
if that is a if that is a real thing now
i should say that
um uh you know black holes
that we see in astrophysics made from
collapsed stars or even larger
uh their their their evaporation time
uh and the evaporation effects of the
quantum physics are essentially
negligible they
it would take so long to lose any
significant amount of energy
that you'd wait longer than the lifetime
of the universe so this is very much in
the realm of
what if in the theoretical physics world
where you're thinking about
the fate of perhaps small black holes if
they were to be discovered
i love that you use the term what if
it's very very rare that we get again
a plug it's the show what if so that
kind of covers what we would see
uh what might be in a black hole and
what might be emanating from a black
hole
uh but if we take this visionary
theoretical journey
uh right to its conclusion what would we
see on the other side of a black hole oh
well that's an interesting question
uh part of the part of the question
would then be i i would have to go well
what do you mean
by the other side uh if you think of it
as
is there another side yes it's a
three-dimensional hole
right and one of one of my gripes that i
have sometimes with how this is
these sorts of things are portrayed in
movies and stuff
uh is they they tend to they tend to
they tend to think of it as like a
circle
and then you sort of fall in and you go
somewhere
but where it's it's more of a it's more
of a sphere you can approach it from
many different directions
and you'd go in so the other side is
sort of a weird thing to think about
because it isn't
you don't mean i think the other side so
much as you mean the other place it may
go to
so you can imagine that there's another
spherical object
somewhere else which is like the other
end of that hole
and you would then emerge from out
coming
out of that and that would be like the
exit does that make sense
oh wow like a wormhole type thing well i
that you know those are among the things
that people have
uh speculated about and you can find
uh solutions of the equations
of relativity which is where we study
black holes
that that um that give you those
scenarios but the the the plumbing is
is higher dimensional than we normally
think of right you think for example of
a
of a like a garden hose right has one
end
and that's essentially a circle a disc
that you go into and then you come out
the other end
instead you would have a whole sphere
which is which is like a higher
dimensional circle and then you come out
the
uh a sphere somewhere else if you were
to engineer a wormhole
as far as we know that um that uh
that's fraught with uh physics
difficulty real stable wormholes
are not thought to be possible as far as
we understand
but it's fun to think about them and of
course we use them in
science fiction a lot yeah and einstein
left the door open for that didn't he
well he not only left the door open he
he
he helped discover the door right the
the original
wormhole uh solution um
was was discovered by einstein and uh
and rosen and there was a paper where uh
they actually pointed out
that you could by examining the geometry
of the of the standard black hole
solution that's used to study real
astrophysical black holes
you can actually see that it contains
the possibility
of indeed going what seems to be into
the black hole
and then coming out another side and
it's like you're
and you're at like exiting from a
different black hole
or it's the same black hole up to you
how you think about it and that was the
wormhole
solution otherwise known as the einstein
rosenbridge
bridge between two different sort of
regions
but as they already observed
uh you'd have to do things like move
faster than the speed of light to
to to to traverse that wormhole um
before it collapsed
a few nuts to crack they tend to
collapse before you can uh do anything
with them
if if anybody's seen the uh the opening
or seen the show raised by wolves uh on
hbo max i believe but
the opening has them essentially
doing exactly what you just described
going through popping out another sphere
uh we're checking out you can watch i
believe it's that just the opening is on
youtube it's worth checking out it's
kind of a
an illustrative vision of that
theoretical idea
um theoretical being sort of the key
word when we're talking about big what
ifs especially something like black
holes and looking through them but
is it possible that these things will be
a little less theoretical
uh theoretical and a little more
concrete as we develop
new technology i i know that there's the
the event horizon telescope and the
virgo cluster
you know there's other bigger telescopes
do you anticipate we're going to be able
to learn a lot more from
these these new eyes on these black
holes
well um the event horizon telescope is
is a wonderful example as you say of
what you can do
with new technology and it's in some
ways it's new technology combined with
old technology in the following sense
what the event horizon telescope is it's
actually a network
of existing telescopes and new ones
being built will be added
it's a network of telescopes all around
the earth
that you connect together by
uh so you're getting them all to look in
the same direction at the same object
and so that essentially gives you one
massive telescope
the size of the earth which is what you
need in order to see
something very far away in great detail
and the technological aspect there is
that you need to somehow
combine all that information from all
those different telescopes
in the right way uh with amazing
computer technology
amazing collaboration by hundreds of
scientists
and they collaborate in order to combine
these data using modern algorithms and
super fast computers to do that
and then essentially turns it into one
giant telescope
so indeed the the landmark thing that uh
you probably all saw in the news
um what was it last year i think it was
last year
right that that first image of the black
hole event horizon
which i remind you because people often
miss this fact it's the first time
we're seeing in any extended sense of
the word seeing
a black hole or at least the event
horizon the shadow of the black hole
against the stuff that's glowing around
it
every other image you've ever seen
depicting a black hole
has been an artist's impression it's
easy to forget that because
you know you see these wonderful artists
impressions of matter
coming off one star and falling into a
black hole it looks super realistic
an artist did that um except in this
case this really is
real data turned into what it would look
like and so
um we're gonna learn a lot more about
black holes that way
and um i think uh uh you know whether or
not the business of whether you can
see into it and see out the other side
or what have you
um which is which is probably going to
remain speculative in
in some sense uh we're going to learn a
lot about the black holes
themselves and and uh
what how they how they uh dominate the
physics
in the core of our galaxy how they
interact with the stuff
they're how they uh different how
different galaxies
black holes are different from each
other as we start imaging other
black holes it's going to be huge the
amount of stuff we're going to learn
from that
and it is awesome that we're really
looking
at the shadow of a black hole uh with
our own eyes
uh for the first time in our history in
our civilization's history
spectacular super cool crazy times
professor thanks very much for taking us
through this
speculative vision quest uh where can
people
go to find your work well um
it's probably easiest to find me on
either instagram or twitter
or facebook but just well just google my
name in physics clifford johnson physics
that's the easiest way rather than
trying to figure out what yeah and
that's
i i would i would also sorry go i was
just gonna say that's what i did and
it brought me down the whole clifford
johnson rabbit hole too so i would
it to your point it's the best place to
start clifford johnson physics maybe usc
as well
yeah and you'll find uh you'll find uh
like i said uh lots of lots of
uh thoughts discussions on my blog
images i share of uh physics ideas or
other things other activities i get up
to
and you'll find your way maybe also to
my non-fiction graphic book
about the nature of the universe which i
wrote and drew a couple of years ago
published by mit
press there's a lot of ideas in there
about space and time and quantum physics
a little bit about black holes and how
you can use them as time machines for
example and things like that
thank you professor johnson uh in
quantum physics there's something called
the observer effect which is
very interesting in that literally what
you see
and what i see of the same thing might
be different
so when you apply it to especially
things as theoretical as black holes
when we're asking well what would you
see if you saw
through a black hole well of course you
know beauty is in the eye of the
beholder as they say who knows what
you're going to see but at least
when you talk to somebody like professor
johnson you at least get
a better guidance system on what you'd
be looking for because
here i'm asking that question in a
two-dimensional sense
and i hadn't even thought that of course
that's idiotic yeah they say
there's no dumb questions but maybe that
was a dumb question
yeah no i always thought too that the
black hole is just a you know it's a
hole
yes and you fall into it you're not
realizing it's spherical or it's
three-dimensional yes of course it's not
a black hole it's a black
orb yes exactly really he sort of helped
us understand that and helped us
understand a few others right well we'll
be seeing more black holes
not coming up anytime soon but as our
technology gets
stronger as we send hubble or web
telescopes into space and
get a better look and usher in basically
a new era of
space exploration and we'll also explore
a little bit more with
professor johnson on the extended audio
podcast now
if you're watching us and you want to
hear more we'll just click on the link
below and you can join the extended
audio podcast if you
are already listening to the audio
podcast don't worry
there's nothing to click on just keep
listening we'll be with you
in just a second now if you are watching
on video and you're leaving us well
thanks for joining us
we'll see you next week on another what
if disgust